hello
everybody out there time for another
movie retrospective for the one that won
the patreon poll this week
was the 1992 adaptation
bram stoker's dracula the francis ford
coppola one yeah classic flick
this is actually a really good play like
i think i saw this in the theater when
it first came out
and i liked it at the time but i think
my appreciation for it has really kind
of grown
over the years um in large part
because i mean really the best thing
about this other than like gary oldman's
performance obviously i think the best
thing about this is the special effects
and i like that francis ford coppola was
like adamant that
they were gonna go like old school for
everything
and so so you didn't get that thing
where
you know sometimes now you see horror
movies and stuff like that that were
made in the early 90s that had like kind
of
dodgy cgi in there and it looks like
really really shitty yeah
so the fact that they used like all
old-school methods like really helped
the movie like become
like timeless in a way kind of like an
old universal flick but it's in color
with a lot bigger budget yeah and it's
it's really interesting because
so what happened uh with this was that i
think the dude that wrote the screenplay
um i think he'd been like uh hawking
this script around since like the 70s
like 1977 which like i said they made um
a jack balance one i think that was in
1977 really made for tv
uh the one with frank langella came out
in 1979 which we'll probably review one
of these days because uh one of you guys
sent it to me and i really really like
that adaptation as well
but the guy that wrote the screenplay
was kind of like well i feel like
there have been like a zillion
adaptations of dracula obviously
but none of them are really really that
close to the book so he wanted something
that was a lot more
book you know focused and you know
because
the earlier ones really like the
universal one with bella lugosi and
stuff like that
those are mostly based on this on the
stage play
so a lot of [ __ ] was like taken out a
lot of you know a lot of characters were
taken out or combined
and over the years like kind of they've
had all these different adaptations
actually cinna massacre did uh uh james
that one guy on cinemassacre he did a
really really entertaining
video where he was he made like he had
like a contest
between like all these dracula
adaptations like which one was the most
faithful to the book
yeah i don't know how you kept them all
straight i don't know either but i was
like because you know
that's what that's what nerds do that's
that's what we nerds do we just like we
love doing that kind of [ __ ] and
every difference in the plot every
single different one every single it was
amazing it's like a really i've watched
it a couple of times because i just
thought it was entertaining
and spoiler alert this one and there was
a bbc version i can't remember what year
that it came out but those two were
actually the most faithful adaptations
weird thing about this one though is
that
even though in a lot of ways it is
really faithful to the book
it also seemed like this is a weird
thing
to say but it's like the most faithful
to the book and also maybe the least
faithful to the book
because it's like it has all the [ __ ]
from the book but then it adds a bunch
of [ __ ] that isn't in there
you know what i'm saying like
particularly all the stuff about
uh the romance angle obviously um and
you know
winona ryder's uh you know character
mina being
the reincarnation of vlad the impaler's
wife
elizabeth and uh that being the reason
that he goes to england i think although
they're not real clear on that in this
version of the story
and it's kind of having him um i guess
what oliver harper did a movie
retrospective on this and he said that
the character of dracula and this one is
played more like a fallen angel which
maybe was the
first i don't know if it was the first
dracula adaptation to do that
but it was for sure like a really
influential one because i feel like a
lot of dracula adaptations that
happened like subsequently went with
that angle as well as what
because in the book i mean if you
haven't read the book
dracula in the book is not a real
complex character he's a monster
he's just like an evil man he doesn't
have any redeeming qualities there's no
romance there's no anything like that
yeah the klaus kenski version of
nosferatu is closer to what the original
um vampire was in the book yeah and in a
way that's really weird to say because i
think that people who haven't
read the original book and have only
seen like some of the adaptations you
could be forgiven for thinking of
dracula as kind of like
this you know a fallen angel or yeah
like a suave [ __ ]
or it being like romantic which a lot of
ones in the 70s did that as well the
jack palance one like i mentioned the
frank langella one
so this version the coppola version
isn't the first dracula to make
the vampire a romantic figure or a
tragic figure
because and it's not even the first one
to add that whole
reincarnation of the dead wife thing
because i'm pretty sure the jack palace
one did that too
and that was in the 70s that might have
been 79 i think dan curtis did that one
but that was because he was he was kind
of influenced by his own
soap opera dark shadows so he wanted it
to have more of like a gothic romance
type of feel
this is still probably the best dracula
movie though
i think i would probably agree with you
on that one wrong with it as the damn
accents
yeah man we gotta talk americans we
gotta talk about keanu yeah counter
roofs i love you i love you kiana yeah
he's good he's good you know
especially you know if i can do an
action you know
what was it john wick yeah john wick
he's awesome and uh
bill and ted's and everything and but he
just can't do a british accent i don't
know why they did that
they should have just let him be an
american well
the thing about it is that i don't think
i don't
know if i think the reason that they put
him in the movie was because he was like
a real up-and-coming star like him both
him and went under writer because they
wanted something
right that was gonna like uh you know
draw in like younger viewers or you know
americans and stuff like that that might
have been put off by british
like you know having british actors in
the leads i guess
even though they're not there's not
really a lead in this other than dracula
i mean it's kind of an ensemble movie
the thing about and like i said i love
keanu reeves and this movie came out so
long ago and
everybody and their mama has like [ __ ]
on keanu reeves
for his performance in this movie so i
don't want to pile on because i do love
him
it's not his performance it's the accent
that's awesome yeah he's a little wooden
but i think he might be wooden because
he's trying hard yeah
so he just the thing about it is that
some actors
um have a lot of range they can play
anything um
but most actors i mean that's pretty
rare most actors have a wheelhouse
you put them in one type of movie and
they're great you try to put them in
another type of movie
yeah not so much it's not so much that
there's a bad actor it's just that
some people just have particular things
that they're good at i think he was also
supposed to be kind of like a retro
uptight you know
[ __ ] victorian type guy also but
mixed with that that british accent and
just him and
it just didn't work if you ask me yeah
he's kind of like now when people talk
about like shitty
you know americans doing shitty british
accents he's like the top of the list i
think i mean there's nothing
there's nothing in this story that
dictates he must be british
yeah he could have just been in america
you haven't you had americans living in
england
sure you know i'm traveling around i
just would have let him have his own
[ __ ] voice
his own normal accent although i don't
know if that would have worked either
because keanu's voice
is very california surfer dude yeah and
it's very very hard
for him to disguise that fact like i
said that's just his voice there's
nothing you do about it that's what he
sounds like
i wouldn't have cast him i you know what
i was thinking about it he doesn't like
ruin the movie or anything like this
it's still a brilliant movie it's
gorgeous to look at
um gary oldman is [ __ ] amazing uh
as dracula he's just like a fantastic i
mean he's a fantastic actor all around
he's one of the ones i was thinking of
when you say like people that have range
he can play just about anything
but i you know it's it doesn't ruin the
movie but it does kind of stick out
but i mean when you have a movie with
[ __ ] gary oldman
anthony hopkins yeah and then you have
like richard e grant
and all these other like great british
actors you know the two of them and
winona two to a
to a smaller extent yeah her accent's
better
but still not that good so i feel like
having these two in there i just think
it was a case of like them
being a little bit miscast is all um
for jonathan harker i can't remember how
old i would have liked to have seen
uh jude law in that role i think jude
law would have been
actually really good and he is uh
british so i think that they
should have gone with british actors if
they were gonna go that route one of the
best things about this movie is that
both of them girls are running around
and damn near [ __ ] see-through
[ __ ] nightgowns man that was the best
thing about the movie
i love come on i love that francis ford
coppola
leaned into he's like i not only want to
make this using only methods that were
in use
at the turn of the 20th century like for
movie making
miniatures back like rear projection all
that kind of stuff
um he's like so we're not only going to
do that but he also
made it this kind of like
you know victorian repression opera type
of thing like he just
dialed the [ __ ] [ __ ] up too blood
tits
like [ __ ] it's just like super over
right but it really really works because
it's like an
opera you know what i mean like it's
really really as
you know i don't want to say it's
overwrought because that sounds like i'm
like [ __ ] on it and i'm not i mean
that in like a really really good like
positive way
20s and 30s though had movies that were
like this yeah yeah
american ones i don't they would they
you couldn't show naked breasts
breast assists but [ __ ] that was damn
near see-through i remember that
yeah yeah they did that too they they
got around it
and another thing too that he wanted to
do oh here's something that i
didn't know but i just like learned this
today because i was kind of watching a
little documentary about it
initially when coppola uh conceived this
movie and it's ironic because winona
ryder
was the one that actually brought him
the script for this because
i guess she felt bad for having to pull
out a godfather three at the last minute
they ended up putting sophia coppola in
there and
that was a decision that uh got a lot of
critics like
you know it's got the movie [ __ ] on a
lot because her performance was kind of
crappy
so winona was like hey no hard feelings
check out this i know how much you love
dracula and here's like this really
original
take on it that's a lot closer to the
book and i know you've been wanting to
do something like that so she kind of
like showed it to him
initially his conception was that
he wanted most of the sets not to be
blank i mean not that [ __ ] you know
crazy but
he wanted the sets to be very um just
not a lot of detail in them so the
costumes would be the major thing
so even from the beginning of the
production when they were thinking about
it he's like i want the costumes to be
like a [ __ ] knockout no black capes
no regular [ __ ] that you would see like
in a regular dracula adaptation
so the woman that designed the costumes
uh she's a japanese woman i can't
remember what her name is but she
definitely wanted to
bring in like a lot of eastern influence
which she did particularly in uh
dracula's he has like those long kind of
asian looking capes and stuff and even
though
a lot of the costume design you could
say it was
some parts of it were like anachronistic
because you know oh they didn't wear
that
in whatever year that was you know like
1897 or whatever
but it's like she really really made it
work i mean the [ __ ]
looks [ __ ] gorgeous like all of the
dresses that lucy and mina wear the
[ __ ]
burial shroud that lucy had with like
that big
frill like around her neck and it's like
that's fabulous
i love love that [ __ ] she comes in with
a baby that was a trip
yeah and i love that they actually
showed that too because i feel like
because that's that's in the book i mean
lucy coming back into
like eating a baby and they see her like
eating the baby it was like eating
little kids and [ __ ] like that so they
didn't really shy away from that in the
movie which i thought was cool
but like i said the whole um aspect of
the movie
where you know that this might have been
like i said one of the first ones
although i think maybe the
jack palance one did it as well that
definitively tied dracula to
actually being vlad the impaler even
though
i was watching something earlier because
i feel like nowadays and maybe because
of this
movie i feel like everybody's like oh
you know dracula was based on vlad the
impaler
not the case um bram stoker
he did actually know the name he got the
name dracula like from that family line
but there's no evidence that he actually
knew much of anything about vlad the
impaler like the actual dude
so it seemed like that kind of
happened later on that you know what i
mean that like the character that he
wrote about they're like oh that kind of
sounds like vlad the impaler because i
guess it was like a bootleg turkish
uh version of the novel that was you
know like released over there in turkish
obviously
and there they like said oh that sounds
like vlad the impaler or somebody like
that
so i think that's kind of how that
happened but i think nowadays i think
everybody just
like takes it for granted that dracula
the character was based on vlad the
impaler
which he wasn't necessarily you know
what i'm saying he just got the name
from that because he thought the name
was cool
yeah originally he was going to call
this is like so funny
originally he was going to call the
vampire count wimpier
yeah i was like vampire little on the
nose there bram
i think uh i think the nosferatu version
i think it was uh count orlock one
it was yeah they had to change it to
warlock because most people
copyrights copyright issues they
couldn't get the copyright to the novel
because it was still on copy right now
you know but yeah so the stuff about him
being vlad the impaler but
that said even though that none of that
is in the book
um i like that edition i like that they
made this like almost a gothic romance
and they also did kind of a thing where
particularly in
mina's character and like i said i love
winning a writer too but i kind of wish
they had
to also cast a british actress for her
role too
but um you know even though she's she
does a lot better than keanu but i still
wish that it was a british actress
but um so i i like that they
almost were making a statement about her
kind of like being like victorian
repressed or because they actually have
her and lucy kind of have some
conversations about this where lucy is
kind of like
[ __ ] and um mina is kind of like man i
wish i could be [ __ ]
but you know everyone will get like all
upset at me because victorian repression
blah blah blah
but then like when dracula comes she's
like oh yeah i'm not
make me a vamp it's like you know what i
mean she just like goes whole hog with
the [ __ ]
so i like that they kind of did because
the novel
you know back in the old days you
couldn't really come out and be like
have all this like
[ __ ] smut in there but some of the
[ __ ]
in the original book dracula is pretty
smutty for the time
and uh people probably would have been
like you know retiring to their fainting
couches like reading some of that [ __ ]
you know what i mean
but i like that that that it they ramped
it up
in this version where it's basically
just like she
she was ready to have him like
bite her and she's like sure i'll become
a vampire and murder innocent people why
not
so he's like we'll just be together
listen that didn't happen in the book in
the book
i mean he did like you know drink her
blood and like trade blood and
everything but he forced her to do it
whereas in the movie she was just kind
of like okay you know what i mean
so uh but you could argue too that he
was kind of
hypnotizing her but i don't know because
she seemed kind of into it
she was pretty into it i think it was
kind of a nod to the belle of the ghosty
version
yeah and i think that's kind of what
they were doing but you know
out of the two
man this one's probably better than the
bellagosi version but bella lugosi for
me was the [ __ ]
definitive [ __ ] count dracula yeah
that's pretty much him yeah even though
not a whole lot happens that movie by
today's standards it's well and it's
very stagey yeah a lot of talking that's
it
yeah um so you could and
like i said it's very strange to think
that the coppola version
is a lot more faithful to the book i was
very happy one of the
things that i was happiest to see um
when i first saw this movie in the
theater back in 1992
was that somebody finally included
quincy morris
for christ's sake that poor [ __ ]
he's like he's in the book and he does
[ __ ] in the book like he's like you know
that's and the way they show him in the
copa movie is pretty much the way he's
described in the book as well like
pretty similar
and i love that i think this might be
the only adaptation that has quincy
morris in it
i think there were a couple other ones i
think there was a british one
and maybe one other one like a [ __ ]
turkish one or a mexican one or
something like that
that had a quincy quincy-like character
but some
what things that a lot of like
adaptations did was like they would
combine two characters we're like we
don't need lucy to have three boyfriends
like to form this like to form this like
you know vampire fighting squad it's
like she doesn't need three of them so
we're gonna like combine them
so i think cheaper for production too
you didn't have to hire as many people
that's true because i feel like i mean i
can see it from a movie-making
standpoint because you're like man this
is a lot of people
and it's a lot of dudes and unless
like you know you want them as like the
dracula busters or whatever but it's
like
do we really need this guy or you know
he only does a couple things so we can
just like make this other dude do his
[ __ ] and then just like write him out of
stuff
yeah so i feel like that's kind of
always what happened with quincy so i
was very very happy to see that he was i
mean he's not
a huge part of the [ __ ] but he does like
do stuff
and i like that they brought back that
aspect of like her having like three
suitors and oh my goodness
i have all these boys that love me and i
can't decide like which one i want to
marry and all this other kind of stuff
so i thought that was like cool that
they
brought that because it it kind of like
you know
bolstered the whole theme of her being
kind of like
not not [ __ ] i mean i'm just you know
just
open with her sexuality and mina being
kind of jealous of that
you know what i'm saying so i think that
that kind of like bolstered that theme
that they were going for
for me what one another thing that stood
out about this movie though was tom
waits
he did i was just gonna say yeah he did
a really good job as a red field
i love tom waits anyway like i love his
music and stuff so i thought it was like
really cool that they put him in there
as rhinefield
yeah that's i don't remember him in any
other movies though
he was in a couple other ones but he's
usually he was in the dead don't die
remember okay that jim jarvis zombie
movie that we saw that's right that's
right
he used to have a reputation being kind
of hard to work with
he seems like he'd be kind of weird he's
kind of crazy yeah he seems like he'd be
kind of crazy like not in a not in a
shitty way but he seems like he's
eccentric let's put it that way yeah he
just seems a little private means drunk
all the time
i don't know what that means i don't
know what the i don't know what they're
he's a little kind of crazy i've seen
some interviews with him when he was a
young guy pretending to be an old man
and he kept breaking character and [ __ ]
yeah
he's like i'm still working out my old
man he starts [ __ ] grin and he's
pretending to be an old guy yeah
i really honestly i think casting him as
renfield was inspired
and some people were like but like i
said some people are like oh it's
overrated over the top or anything like
that but that's what this whole [ __ ]
movie was it's like i said it's like an
opera like the way that it looks is like
an opera
it's like anthony hopkins like acting
like a crazy person
um you know and [ __ ] like that but he
but he plays van helsing
and he's kind of like you can tell that
in his backstory he might have fought
some vampires before like in the past
and maybe like addled him a little bit
so he he seems exactly like
like i imagined van helsing would be
yeah which is kind of strange because
anthony hopkins plays the same character
oh constantly he kind of does yeah he's
just always plays himself
he's always ahead of me hopkins can you
come in and be anthony hopkins for us
yeah sure
sure i can do that sure i could be give
me my 40 million dollars thank you very
much yeah
but he's but he's so brilliant that it's
like yeah you can't
like his job you can't be mad that's his
job well that's what he gets hired to do
they're like they hire anthony hopkins
to be anthony hopkins exactly
he's not one of those actors that like
vanishes into a role
no he's not a dustin hoffman yeah you
need somebody that's like he was like
bigger than life and i think that was
like really good that they cast him as
ben helsing because
he was came across as uh bigger than
life his job is to come in and class the
[ __ ] place up that's what he does
that too he classes the place up
and and like i said i think that was
what made uh keanu and winona suffer a
little bit by comparison just because
like not only like i said you have gary
oldman giving like easily one of the
best performances of his career
and you had to think too that gary
oldman had to play
dracula in all his different iterations
like looking like an old man looking
like a young man looking like a bat
looking like this like that
so it's just the fact that he had to
play it all like that and he came across
with such um you know pathos and he came
across
as like evil but still kind of
sympathetic um
but you understood like why he had to be
destroyed because
you know he was kind of like a tragic
figure so i just thought that was like a
really really good performance and i
mean [ __ ] man some of his lines from
this have become like iconic
i also want to give a shout out to
richard e grant who really needs to be
in more movies because i love that dude
but um
i knew i think that he got this job
because francis ford coppola really
liked uh with nail and i which if you
haven't seen that it's like a
[ __ ] is a great [ __ ] british movie
uh but yeah he was in this playing dr
seward also like
over the top but in the best possible
way but yeah it's like and sadie frost
too playing lucy i really liked her
as well i was gonna mention when we were
talking about keanu
and his um not not being so good at
these types of roles
i will note too that he was also cast in
dangerous liaisons the one that had john
malkovich
and uh glenn close in it which is a
[ __ ] i was one of my favorite movies
ever i love that [ __ ] movie
about how to [ __ ] other people over it
is it's great it's
a [ __ ] great movie um and keanu he
doesn't ruin that one either
because i mean his part is like pretty
small
um so he's not like you know sneaking up
the joint too much like
no no i'm sorry i'm sorry keanu i really
do love you
but he had the same issue in that even
though they didn't really make him
i don't remember them making him talk in
a british accent or a french accent
because it's
supposed to take place in france but
everybody was just talking with their
mostly normal voices
but he was still trying to be like i'm a
historical period piece
and it just it wasn't working out so
it's i don't know i think maybe
those are the only two movies that i can
think of and there might have been more
it's like somebody correct me but
those are the only two movies that i can
think of that were like historical
dramas like period pieces that they put
him in and then after that they're like
yeah let's not do that anymore
he's too modern like we've talked about
that before
some actors some people's faces some
people's voices
it just doesn't translate like you don't
believe that that person
was alive back then you know what i'm
saying and and when you're doing a
period piece you really need people that
look like they could have
lived back then because otherwise you
know you can't suspend your disbelief
and he's just one of those people that
he's just too california
yeah he's just too modern he's just too
much of a modern person
you can't his whole like um his whole
aura
is a modern guy in california i mean
just the way that dude
that's what i mean it's just like a
whole thing it's just it's how he talks
it's his facial expressions it's
everything
and you just never and i never bought it
for a second and dangerously is
liaison take one thing by reeves so that
[ __ ] can shoot
well you watched him at the range
[ __ ] work he's good with pistols
rifles and everything
a lot of that uh [ __ ] [ __ ] you see
him doing in um in the john wayne
john wick's flex he can do yeah he can
do
like he's got head shots multiple head
shots on [ __ ] man targets
out to about 20 meters he's [ __ ] fast
fast reloads everything
he's got proper training i mean he just
he does that [ __ ] he rides motorcycles
in some ways kind of like tom cruise tom
cruise actually can do a lot of [ __ ]
these yeah to show them do it you can
even fly aircraft you know
which like i said you got to respect
that yeah because that's somebody that's
taking acting to like a whole new level
they're like i'm really going to learn
to do this
those are lifestyle guys they just don't
want to make movies and do they want to
do
cool [ __ ] too you know yeah which i
respect that they're not just sitting
around
you know [ __ ] getting drunk and
screwing hookers and [ __ ] like old tiger
blood
that's his name charlie charlie
charlie's seen you sit around just like
hookers all day
yeah and then just go pretend to be yeah
something else spread diseases
that spread diseases yeah like you do
but yeah so
well yeah and like i said no no ding on
keanu it's just that he's not
like a period piece dude no a lot of
actors aren't
um and like i said it's nothing against
them it's just something about how they
look or walk or talk or
how their face looks or something like
that that you just don't believe it
and um but as i said you know that said
he doesn't ruin this movie uh even
though because
in a way like you said it does kind of
work in the sense that he's supposed to
be like this kind of
uptight stick in the mud sort of
character yeah so the woodenness kind of
works
it's the accent it's really yeah shitty
they they made it it's a dumb decision
coppola should have known better
she should all they had to do is just
add a line that she was her
fiance or husband fiance right yeah they
married in the
course of that that's right yeah that
she was his fiancee from america
that's all he had to do yeah and just
let him be american and it would have
been it made a lot more sense because
quincy was american
yeah i mean he was american in the book
too yeah but that well that's
yeah that's the thing it's like either
get a british actor or explain that he's
from the united states that's all like
like you said that's all it would have
taken
yeah that's all it would have taken is
just like one line because
you know yes they wanted to make the
most faithful adaptation of the book
which they did because like i said a lot
of the stuff is
is actually faithful to the book and
they even did like the whole epistolary
style like
you know doing with the ship logs and
the diaries and everything like that and
switching perspectives which the book
does too
so they did that but it's like it it
really seemed like
that would have been a very simple you
know and they added the whole romantic
subplot and the whole vlad the impaler
thing and that wasn't in the book so
it's like
added that he was from boston and had
him do a transatlantic [ __ ] accent
because he could do a transatlantic and
there you go
yeah like i said as long as he didn't
one thing that i see a lot of is that
people that are talking about this movie
because most people that have reviewed
this movie or seen this will like love
this movie
except for him like but they say like
they don't it doesn't ruin it but
it just it just sticks out yeah um just
because the rest of the movie is so
awesome like the visuals and all the
acting and everything like that this he
just kind of like sticks out
but um i just i don't know i feel like a
lot of people are like well
every time he's on screen i expect him
to go dude
yeah which you do kind of they should
have made
they dracula that in the 1800s so you
see the dude from texas and he goes
you dude you're a dude dude oh my god
that would have been that's all he had
to do
he could have called quincy because they
did have that word
dudes yeah quincy
[Laughter]
all right they need me around if i can
tell them what to do because that
that joke that joke would have [ __ ]
sent that movie to another level
it's because it's just right there
between like brilliant and stupid
you know what i'm saying it's right
there on that night [ __ ] aren't you a
dude
dude yes i am a dude
that might have been like really funny
actually now i kind of want to see that
but yeah all right yeah so
anyway i find it very hard to believe
that anyone has not seen
bram stoker's dracula from 1992 even if
you haven't seen it i'm sure you've seen
like
the zillions and millions of different
parodies of it like they paired it with
the simpsons they paired it on [ __ ]
in living color whatever the [ __ ] of the
show that's a type of a masterpiece
actually it is yeah and like i said i
think
that one of the things other than you
know gary oldman being
like [ __ ] epic in the show tom wait
tom wade's being epic in the [ __ ] pretty
much everybody being epic
except for those two but um you know i
think like
the look of it is has gone a long way
too
toward like making it a classic because
you know not only are the costumes
[ __ ]
amazing just like the whole thing is
just like amazing looking
every single thing that they wear is
like just [ __ ] amazing
but also the way that coppola was like
stuck to his guns
and because initially when they were
first like you know before they started
like working on the movie
his first like special effects crew were
like dude we need to like do all this
stuff with computers and he said
absolutely not and he would not let them
do it and then like the crew bitched and
he said
and he fired all of them and so he got
like his son to come in and like
oversee the [ __ ] he's like i don't want
any computer effects
at all i want everything done the way it
would have been done
in the very very earliest days of cinema
and that's all there is to it and the
fact that he stuck to his guns
and they found these like really because
if you um if you have the
dvd or the blu-ray they usually put like
a um and you can probably find it on
youtube too for all i know but they have
like a documentary about how they did
all the effects watch that [ __ ] because
that
it's amazing like how they did some of
the effects
and that's all [ __ ] that they would have
done like back in the early days
of special effects you know when you
didn't have computers you couldn't like
fall back on that it was
you know so i think the fact that he did
them old school
and he had it had a particular style
that like draws you into the movie and
it has like a whole particular look and
like a fantasy like opera kind of look
to it
i think that's gonna make it like
timeless it doesn't seem
like a movie from the 90s or it doesn't
seem like
an old movie you know what i'm saying
when you watch it because it just has
that kind of like timeless
quality to it yeah so yeah
if you haven't seen it which like i said
i'd be very surprised if you hadn't then
you should probably see it i think it's
on netflix at the
moment or maybe shutter i can't i don't
even know uh but yeah so
check it out and uh tell me in the
comments
who you would have rather seen play
jonathan harker than chiarate reeves
jude law was my was my thing but i'd
have to like go back to see what other
like younger british actors were kind of
around at that time because i can't
really remember but jude law was the
first one that i thought of
but yeah so uh let me know what you
think in the comments and that'll do it
for our
retrospective on bram soaker's dracula
and we'll see you on the next one
bye